here we
go full steam
open now I may or may not have is this
the right way
yeah is this right um check the map
think so Jack yeah this is right cuz I
got to go to that red thing yeah okay I
may or may not have spoiled a little bit
of this for myself because at the end of
the last episode I was like they show
you like the contraption oh I remember
okay so before this you were talking
about the metal thing hanging from the
ceiling okay I know I was like I'm going
to go on ahead even though we're not
going to save it and you were like don't
do that and then I got here and I saw
this which looks like something out of
that movie yeah saw thank you or Empire
Strikes Back that one scene with Han
Solo and the the
zombie
right yeah it's kind of kinky there's
also an episode no a movie about a bunch
of rooms and each room contains a
different monster and it kind of reminds
me of that but I don't remember what
it's called Cabin in the Woods the end
well that's not let's not spoil that
okay
Ashley that's what you're talking about
I think right the elevator you know what
there's actually another movie where
there's a different monster in every
room of a house they like all have to
get out B and
Toyland
a it's got a bunch of nipples on
it yeah it does yeah it does e what is
that who is that is that somebody I
know what am I
doing
can I kill
it what you just want to progress
through this thing got it
okaying
done how do I do I push that
button shoot you can shoot it the button
yeah probably would use a shotgun though
okay got it yeah yeah that makes sense
why actually you don't have much handgun
ammo why would you shoot a a button I
don't
know if only I had like a I think I'm
telling you too much right now like a
boomeranger thought I had
a he did but
yeah there must be another
one he's here he's
somewhere I found him he's there
is it all the way over
[Music]
there this is a stupid Labyrinth for
stupid [__] and you're right in the
middle of
it okay oh
okay that was surprising the timer is
far scarier than that dude
was [__] I thought I could you know him
you should heal oh
[__] how do I run faster x
uh you're doing it right now aren you
just go to the door
yeah okay it's going to
fall you're right who did design this
thing like in uh in resid evil one and
two they just they kind of tell you why
why the mansion and the police station
are
um designed the way they are wait it
won't open but there's got to be a way
you're yipping more than my C and I
don't even have a
c well that's why I Y
more one doesn't
exist are you making up one from
Mary oh my God I got it I got it I got
it I don't think you do I got it nice oh
and you're already you're already where
you need to go really yeah like meant
face
one why are there all these double
switches are you not seeing a pattern
emerging
no I found you he's
here all
right where
is for [__] sake there's no other oh
idiot there's only one
switch
[__] hate that
guy am I supposed to you already shot
that one all
right there you go
oh this so exciting
that didn't sound good
didn't just let me hit this button real
fast Excuse me while I kiss this
guy
um jeez I think that's where you never
mind no no I'm
wrong okay okay so you can okay um you
can shotgun or you can like hurt him
enough that it'll stun him well I mean
you've seen if you heard him in the
right way he'll go back up to the
ceiling I've been shooting him in the
tongue in the in the
boobs oh I did not hit that button combo
really ugly but damn does you have a
nice sixpack or six boobs either way I'm
I'm into it okay
so [__]
you you're going the wrong way what yep
oh no you missed a grenade but that's
fine [__] the Gren
grade see you why isn't he dead cuz he's
on the
ceiling
button
um everyone gets PP back wh up
what have thought that you should heal I
can't I'm in C no I meant
like you know I can't you have a lot of
green herbs how about this one yeah
sure that sounds good that one looks
good okay I'm
stressed me too what do I shoot all of
it some of it yeah which mouth put
bullets in
it [__] off
yeah thank you jeez
shocker all right I think look above it
oh no no no no you're you're
right gosh you can't see me in
here yeah I know I
know for what's sake
no
oh you have one shot one chance don't
[__] it
up I got
it wow I think you're
good
okay oh [__] something's going to
happen I feel
it
I hope he doesn't come out this time
just leaves me
alone Jesus CH where is it where is the
thing damn it I got slice run just run
just run bones through there through
there through there
oh that's right yes I don't have a lot
of
time you just force one out
quick is that it did I do it I hope so
God willing
Jesus drink beer later I thought it was
done I thought I had enough time you
finished him you'll never see him
again oh sweet all that sweet TMP if you
haven't watched the first what like 14
episodes of this a bun this play through
you know how funny it is every time TMP
ammo I oh no now just [__] [__]
waste him it's going to take a
lot well I mean don't get hit oh no I'm
going to
die so
what would you
recommend is best to kill this guy we'll
definitely heal
first
um
grenades would be good right now
okay but definitely get has he faster
than me I feel like pretty oh
barrel uh you don't well I I know S I
thought you were going to shoot it right
there do it
now nice got you you prick all
right do shock grenades work on him or
no oh uh flashbangs
okay Arham yeah there you
go more
Arc too much Arc too much dial back the
ark what
about this is like a bad episode of Star
Trek set your guns to to less
Arc put some Noah on that
Ark ooh ooh too much again I heard him
he made a noise you can open that gate
over there and then does that help I
think there's another Barrel in there
sounds
good that sounds real
good it's a
lver ooh nice your handgun's pretty
powerful at this point yes yes
yes yeah use that
bar show yourself you ugly dick stroke
that sweet fuel drum did I I feel like I
didn't get him enough I don't think so o
but your vision's blurry
why is it cuz I'm
scared there must be Molly in those
herbs wait where is he is he on this
hill okay like hand a rifle maybe how
about yeah how about this you got a lot
of ammo yeah it's just about spikes
though like I like to use that for those
spiky guys regenerators your arch and
nemeses oh he's too
close
what's he doing
oh he's doing some kind
of scissors
move what if I operated that and then I
got stuck in there with him then I was
like I'm not stuck here wait with you
you are stuck in here with
me where is that from a movie yeah which
which
movie a movie thanks I don't know I just
I just say the
line nice it went far smoother than I
could have
predicted have you died a lot recently
or
something I'm insulting you I hope you
know that
I didn't pick up on
50,000 pass it uses wait holy
[__] that's a lot of
money oh sweet oh my God you guys so
much
money it's me being you being someone
else it's a good impression thank you I
am going to switch to
handgun
and yeah it's good
you're inching closer to the end of
resum 4 y till I get that sweet plastic
in my hands everyone was like I love how
many people are looking forward to you
playing
considering I've been bossing you around
for how long has it been now how many
episodes total I mean for this is
episode 15 of Resident Evil 4 I think
it's the longest one yet no no no yeah
damn we started this one a while ago we
plowed through the first two cuz we were
doing like two episodes a week I'm not
sure if this is where I was supposed to
go I think so so there's this upstairs
but then there was also it's going to be
funny if I suck like a
trolley let's hope you play better than
you no see I feel like I should go
back cuz like this looks like it's
taking me somewhere here I'll show you
like what's
this uh I got a question wait see or
just press it well
you should be faster if you don't want
me to do those
things
um damn
it you slob got I got it dropping beef
jerky down your shirt I've could not
have said a more like grotesque thing
beef jerky not how I said it you're just
mad cuz you just dropped a hunk of meat
but I got down your
Linens all right I don't know what I'm
doing wait did you just pull that out
the bottom of your yes if it goes in the
front comes out the this is on
YouTube it's still good jerky I
understand how shirts work I just don't
think you realize the extent to
which I didn't see anything it was just
jerky anyway where am I going like
should I go keep going this way it's
been a long day uh okay pull up your map
I'm surprised it's not your first that's
where you were that's the thing that
fell oh stop chewing in the mic please
oh my God this is devolving already it's
been like I don't even know how long
it's been 10
minutes I beat a boss all right so
here's my
argument I can either take that back to
where I was but it's like I'm supposed
to go this way yeah so why not go that
way I don't know cuz I don't know why it
would give me that option just to return
to the merchant if you want to go back
to the merchant right now and buy [__]
before you progress cuz you just use a
lot of ammo uh
oh at least I think I don't know to
spend my petas
yes I don't know what I'm going to do
anymore when I don't have to say petas
as much really yeah what are they in
five
uh pearls something tells me it's
something
like let me look that
up there definitely
money haha you guys are dumb
I don't think I should jump down I feel
like
there's I can still hear a chainy
man I do want those items
though where is he is he coming up the
ladder he's coming up the ladder oh so
it's oh it's kind of Yen damn it which
doesn't make sense takes place in Africa
but it's a Japanese game [__] you it's a
y with what I wanted an N with two lines
in it kind of like a y with two it's
just made up I guess again I don't know
we'll figure it out next
[Applause]
play that gu kept going he sure did
cool
cool oh I
hear
something
I don't like being near
barrels okay down this
hole or around the
corner which one seems safer to
you sounds like a
proposition
yeah this a very innuendo in innuendo
Laden episode uh probably down the hole
I would say down the hole or wait
actually there's a yellow herb get that
for sure cuz I think you're at full
health once you use this one no no I
think you have to go down the
hole okay like Alice or
Neo do you know there's a matrix
reference in Alice and Wonderland the
White
Rabbit what do you mean Alice in
Wonderland came first I know that was
the joke oh uh it was a bad one no that
was
funny uh I can see a door in the
distance I need to find another way
there okay thank you that Mark's the
first time I've read something in this
ever Ser I don't think I've ever no the
character Mike is coming up I'm not
kidding I'm I [__] you not let's go does
he work
out he
[Laughter]
better oh he's bigger than
Leon nah nobody's cooler than Leon I
said
bigger I know I like bigger mus cows I
would say those those two are parallel
um all
right oo that looks
dangerous everything looks for
boating oo that looks like something you
would put in a
cat I hit the wrong button I got it I
put a lot of things in my cat
I don't understand yes you do no I don't
oh you need one
more a stupid cat have have two eyes
like a normal
cat just need that piece for his
Dome oh it's my friend oh what's
that secret can I say it's refreshing
how little you're checking your map
thank
you [__]
you all
right should I spend these patas
oo was this note on a
knife did he write a whole note on here
that's impressive also why did he leave
it down
here with my last knife I leave this
message even though I succeeded in
kidnapping Ashley I sort of sensed this
when Sadler didn't wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait even though I
succeeded in
kidnapping Ivanka thank you under the
circumstances I had no other alternative
but to call for her assistance perhaps
she knew this was the way it was going
to turn out all along my guess is that
her ultimate goal might be different
than Wesker in
mine after I get rid of Leon and
retrieve the sample I'll put her in a
body bag along with Leon and send them
both to
Wesker I'm a big bad man
welcome
hello got some rare things on sale
stranger what are you
selling some TMP ammo is that all
stranger no techn
magnetic ums so I'm keeping this I think
so yeah and I think that's it yep all
right that was well you actually have a
lot of money what are you buying you
could do some decent
uh
upgrades yeah what are you
buying wait hold on keep going
down what's coming
up um I would say go for the uh broken
butterfly instead of this one yeah what
are you buying final boss fight I mean
yeah just do that just do sure I think
you already at the damage which one all
of them I think you can afford it all
yeah I can afford you can almost afford
all three of the well actually you could
afford do
Firepower is that all and reload speed
cuz capacity capacity gives me all those
bullets
though is that old stranger yeah but by
the time you actually need this gun
you're not you're not going to yeah do
that you're not going to have time to
fire more than one round you're only
going to I can do another Firepower sure
no I can't no you can't yeah just yeah
come back time I will thank you you
honestly wouldn't have to upgrade the
rest of the game you'd be fine but it's
just fun to do so and people are saying
you're missing out by not getting the
treasure maps and stuff I like you don't
need that much money I'm
richer off your
feet you peasant it's the oxygen
absorber is that what that
is so if you ate it would you not be
able to bre okay that was just in your
mouth what am I supp it Tak all the
oxygen out of your
bloodstream strangles you with it okay
seriously I'm not kidding you're like
making out with that thing while you
eat it's bothering me I have misophonia
have we talked about this before I think
people just say you get annoyed easily
Pete Brown here at gam spot and me here
at game gam
spot have
misophonia get triggered by small sounds
you're coming up on you're coming up on
the end of the game you're almost there
and we're about to meet Mike and what a
glorious several minutes of fame he
has I Hae the rest of your jerky so you
couldn't yeah that's why so you couldn't
okay while you're playing the game My
puzzle is to figure out okay got to do
this nobody saw that it's off camera
yeah that's I'm showing them now it's in
there they didn't see you do it I took
my beer and pushed it when I jump down
something is going to
happen I'm going to reload all my
weapons you're a regular sleuth thank
you also that's got [__] ton of handgun
ammo
recently I love that you're in Egypt all
of a sudden
yeah Shinji Mami in his like brainstorm
meeting I didn't even second guess it
but now that you say
that what he went from a Spanish village
to a
castle a military enforced militarily
enforced Island to a
laboratory to the sandst stwn
post-apocalyptic Saudi Arabia I'm quite
a world traveler what the [__] is going
on I don't
know what is
that
what you asking what that that is those
Flames fire cut scene quick quick you
two are all hooked up now is that it
where's Ashley I got my quick time
buttons ready you really want to know
they both talk with her jaw punch she's
beyond that
gate oh but you'll need three insas to
open it thanks for telling me what are
you going to do
ker there's one in the North and the
other in the East that's two and let me
guess you got the last one it's up my
butt pretty much means you're on a tight
leash the third Insignia is my dick
sounds like you thought this went out
pretty well except for explaining
everything I'm
Batman what's the point of telling me if
you're going to kill me all right it's
going to get loud what am I doing uh
getting those Insignia he just told you
you Me Oh I thought I was supposed to
kill him well I mean he's he's
definitely a nuisance but those Insignia
are your
your objective is he throwing grenades
at me okay can I kill him or
no we'll get to that but I would focus
on not letting him shoot you right now
all right should I run up those stairs
maybe reloads yeah
go who's he talking to I'm not even
listening to him yeah he thinks you are
though megalomaniac um can I yeah do I
have time
yeah
uh can you open that yet I don't I don't
[Music]
know he's so
sneaky so you can fight him
I there I shot you you should be
dead oh he stabbed me you should
heal ah [__] okay I'm going to let you
fight him
do what you
will here's my one hint uh he doesn't
like hold on before you go back well but
there's something he doesn't like
there's something he likes even less
than that and uh do you remember the
last qte cut scene with him what you
were doing and everything every time you
see a note by him like what it shows
just like take that into
account
and he's
insecure you're thinking way too hard
this isn't a psychological evaluation of
Crower I'm just saying what doesn't like
colors cuz he's always wearing black
okay never mind we'll talk about it if
you die you might raid of
scars a mirror I need to get a
mirror okay I give up we'll talk about
it next time if you die you had nowhere
to go I do there's a there's a trick to
beating him should that not have killed
him no he's a boss but he's a
man he's just a man he's not a man he's
a
machine
nice what if he just kissed you on the
cheek wait okay so shooting him isn't
working yeah shooting him is working
it's just not the most efficient way and
I'm go the other way I guess or shoot
him
yeah I don't know where to
go sorry yeah uh I mean you're going the
right way you just got to but he's a
really good knife wound him wait there
was nowhere to go that
way I mean like if you hurt him enough
the timer on the door wasn't yeah but
that's like that's that's just the
justification for you hurt him before
you go through the door okay you don't
have to shoot him is what I'm
saying never mind just do I just have to
avoid him no there are other things you
could
do never mind you're okay I'm making you
think too hard just shoot him a mirror
oh shoot him oh shoot him that's
horrifying this is like have you seen
get out have you seen get out yeah you
dead you know what I'm talking
about damn oh [__] you oh he [__]
you look at him I know what he's doing
behind me but I'm not going to
look cuz it's dumb if this was like
Raiders the Lost Arc shoot him in the
face when he's doing all this fancy
nonsense to
like do something oh he's so fast there
you go oh
cool
idiot he's doing all these stupid flips
he looks like an
idiot oh my God he slit my throat you're
alive that's weird I don't think I'm
doing very well do you have full health
oh you're close did you use that yellow
herb earlier yeah oh all
right
[Music]
um yeah no you're doing fine you have a
lot of he I don't feel like I am I don't
either but you are I'll get those
barrels no get those BR he's coming he's
not yeah he
is
nice
Oh I thought this was all about like
wait don't yeah there's nothing up here
oh you're
right I shot you that was good
a well I don't feel like he means
that like all the way or all right I'll
pick
one oh it's
cage I feel like a cage doesn't work on
a lever like I could still lever it yeah
pretty wide set
bars I can definitely like get a stick
in there
and it's an Insignia wait where have I
heard about
this sh intend to do restoring umbrella
up to bring order and balance to this
insane world of
ours like you order or balance you
don't
mind can CH a new course for the world
do you that movie is based on the the
cat and the
hat got one piece of the Holy Beast
uhoh ooh red herb get that okay
sweet uh before you leave this air o I
love how if you're midair grenades don't
hurt you oh he's going to hit you be
Wier
come get me you
loser where am I going to get the second
piece of the
Insignia
um but I I
can't I can't believe he's not shooting
me neither can I this game this is like
the most beloved game
right uh I would say yeah it's a fair
assessment I don't just leave the area I
didn't know
how I know it sounds just stand there
come out and fight like a man I'm not
falling for that one
just got you you press go like this that
way oh is it this I'm fairly positive
you don't have to be doing what you're
doing right now I just don't know what
I'm doing maybe you do have to shoot him
yeah I guess you shoot him when he comes
down oh
no like there's nowhere for me to go
yeah just fight him I guess I don't want
to well you have to I think I'm a
peaceful
protester this is like hacksaw Ridge the
worst movie to ever get a Best Picture
Nom I shoot him in the [__] face oh
no you got him you're good watch out for
the grenade
though o oh he dodged me he's just
slicing me up something
fierce
you're fine oh right oh I thought I
threw him over the edge that' be pretty
sweet [__] is this right I don't feel
like I'm doing a very good job I mean
you're doing it one way you want me to
tell you you can use your knife and it's
like his vein all
right like when he's close to you using
your knife [__] him
up
nice it it like hurts him a
lot it's a knife off is it
there okay sweet should open should be
fine there you go jeez jeez Lou Papa
cheese I thought when you said like no I
was just trying to that's like the one
thing about the Crower fight everybody
talks about like just use your knife and
it's kind of counterintuitive because he
seems like a dangerous guy why wouldn't
you use a shotgun to his face and it
makes more sense cuz he likes so yeah
you brought a gun to a knife fight and
it pissed him off uh I think
he trans yeah that's
you just keep pushing into the wall for
I think it's like 20 seconds mhm you
beat the game
mhm I don't know where I'm going just
push it to the other to the other one
that makes
sense he did he disappear too by the way
yeah he ninja banished vanished ninja
banish ninjab banishing is basically is
vanish when you
banish that's from Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles right ninja banishing oh you
just [__] that up oh no no no no just
push I mean not permanent no no no you
didn't yeah you're
good what happens if you do push it into
a wall and you can't get it out I think
they designed this area to not let you
do that you can definitely do it you put
it in a
corner like
here yeah but the corner slanted look at
it so you I don't know I I've never
tried it to be frank
but your
mic
yeah that was a good
one you're doing well I don't have any
concerns well I have many concerns
regarding you but your performance in
this game that's all I care about
yes what a
creep what a nice psychopath good knife
oh knife off I mean you can use weapons
as well but yeah your knife is I mean
you're doing too much yeah see it's like
hurting him way more he's leading to the
flashbang
sooner I like that he uses flashbang as
a way to get away where he could like
use it to kill me oh what are those what
Nano robots come or not nano I'm an
idiot those are small uh Spider what
just shoot him it's dumb but yeah just
shoot him we'll Breeze past the logic
but can we like talk about this don't
think too hard about this game it gets
dumb toward the end there you go okay
why all right I I urge you this game is
the most beloved in the series and it
has Nano robots Okay those aren't Nano
robots I'm dumb because Nano robots are
tiny they're Nano oh he's got you he's
got you pegged what is he doing he's
going to blow up next to you res Evil 5
is ending no matter what happens here is
dumber than res evil
4S stop walking towards those sorry I
thought it had no no consequences
because it didn't
okay I got some rifle ammo out of it
there work
down shoot
him what is what is going on it's a
weird one-off thing I promise that
doesn't happen the rest of the game
but
why should I eat
this sure I'm running out of herbs cuz
these stupid
morons
ooh wait don't walk for
yeah I can see it's not like it's that
[__] hidden it's you just walked into
one 5 seconds ago yeah but that was
before before I was aware the Nano
robots were
thing my past I suppose I like
responding
umbrella
stop drinking beer at the most
inopportune times L you just never max
out your your health now or when you get
the chance just save it that one tick
isn't going to do much
difference
knives
there's a bunch of IES out
here oh just one that's still cool
though do you remember when I did an
entire episode with
like maybe a pixel of Health well I mean
the last 10 minutes wait no yeah it was
it was the last like 10 minutes of
episode I know what you're talking about
but let's not exaggerate was a lot it
was a pretty intense episode it's signia
it's a hawkk I feel like Eagle this is
important
somehow this is a weird now I just knife
the [__] out of him it's like they
didn't down one more to goer according
to you the guy who told me about
the wait a minute have you seen have you
played have you played prototype cuz I'm
pretty sure this is where they got the
idea for that game what is happening
gotas plas dictating his every move
witness the power
you've lost it completely
ker prepare for your death Leon am I
actually supposed to knife
this what's going on Dynamite a wait
should I run you could shoot him too but
knifing is very powerful when he gets
close to you like he's got a bird wing
or
something
oh [__] he slit my throat pretty
seriously
there that didn't do a lot got full
health at
least
um oh
right do I have to do the whole fight
from scratch or I honestly don't
know this is it this is all my
OES well don't run toward him well I
thought I didn't I wasn't thinking that
through [__] I can't get close to him
let him come to
you keep walking toward
him wait do that his feet but don't
shoot his shield
um this isn't going well shoot his feet
shoot his
feet there you
go
[Music]
um
died can I drink my beer now
sure [__] I wonder how far back I
am just right
here
cool yeah I like you kept running toward
him like don't don't do that I thought
it would surprise
him nobody expects
that
whatever he's like a knife guy you know
it's like
prare for your death Leon
okay
okay stop shooting his shield please
legs oh [__] even the game is pissed off
I'll
say
that's when you need knife him
yeah oh I've got [__] [__] up with
that
corner there you go yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh [__] I'm like stuck in a
corner I'm not sure just stop trying to
shoot
him
[__] [__] you're doing fine like it's
doing a lot do better yeah don't worry
about the yellow herb yet don't
even just do two
greens or can wait no do greens in
yellow can you or no yeah yeah just do
that you can do whatever you want ooh
never mind you can't do
that just do that just do that just use
that
whatever yeah so okay after you dodge
him then you can go tournament knife him
but just like be ready but I did no late
though nice yeah that's just that works
too fall off the edge oh that's when you
want to get ready for the QT and knife
him
yeah what
uh all right I'm bleeding excessively
really I don't have any other advice you
know I just had them all up
there oh
no oh [__] I'm out of bullies I need
those oh well yeah there you go
nice oh [__] The Shield the thing you
told me nice
no
nice yeah what did you do did you shoot
him I don't know I don't I don't either
did you shoot him no I don't know what
happened but you got him yes uh yeah get
that and go well I hope it's you've got
a minute so Herb in his butt or
something I'm dying that's a long time
you're fine
uh wait wait pick that up
yeah yeah he's not a good guy anymore we
get it Leon shut up stop being
pensive you got to check him at least
twice for oh my God I'm almost dead
that'd be fun if that killed fall damage
absolutely not all right where I better
than summer damage where am I going how
do I get down shut
up I'm really upset you're fine okay
um
actually
dude well yeah go back up I guess dude
okay there's nothing down here we've
discovered that you're fine I'm going to
die okay the timer you're fine just calm
down go that way yes now jump
down other way yeah there you go just
put all three in and you're
okay the timer's still counting down
right now no it's not I
know so he had the panther all
along so
simple sweet back to laboratory
aesthetic yes we're getting there got
time for a little more
I we should beat the game I mean this
episode we should beat the game uh
you're not that
close you're not in this episode we have
another we can do another
episode no I wasn't brushing on you I
was brushing off the
table oh mama I'm going to eat that
right uh don't use that yet dude you
might find a red one right around the
corner I just saved yeah don't worry
about
it it's that guy that robe
guy settler so it seems you killed
krower
too how shall I return my
appreciation what are you talking about
I thought he was with
you h
what are you talking about did you
really think i' trust an
American to tell you the truth I was
contemplating how to get rid of him but
thanks to you that's no longer
necessary you were just using him right
from the start oh I must hand it to you
you've demonstrated quite a bit of
Promise by killing
kower when your assimilation with Las
plagas is complete I'll have you serve
as my card unfortunately I'm going to
have to decline your generous offer I
have prior
engagements enjoy your smart mouthing
while you
can I love my smart mouthing it's one of
my best
features oh you should use that herb I
remember this part oh for [__] sake oh
my God okay but our boy Mike is coming
in
hot
damn yeah [__] yeah o man it's your boy
Mike hey it's about time sorry bad
traffic I'll cover you
yeah Sky traffic guy's a
liar get
I love that rocket dude just walks
around with a loaded rocket launcher
yeah
I'm going to take
lunch now that's what I call backup her
name is Mike you're looking for fire
power you come to the right
place yeah it's Mike with the Firepower
you should heal
I
it's your boy Mikey hey Mikey Southside
coming at you hey how you doing I got
some chain guns I got some Rockets what
you need you want both
[Laughter]
ay hey Leon you ain't looking so good
doesn't matter I got a
helicopter
oh oh don't let him shoot you
okay check that Barrel
W I'mma eat you no more yeah I just hold
that
until so he's pretty much just shreding
folks for you I think you can push
that maybe not yeah hey got guess I
can't get in there hey remember that
turret me
neither
go down first uh to your
right oh this
sh rifle
him or grenade him either
one
nice just run yeah just run [__] it no
what yeah just run straight where you
were
going I have time for this yeah now
run shoot that shoot that
lock Mike yay I got your back
Leon oh
[__] oh nice
yeah this game just becomes an utter
[__] show toward the end I
mean like this is a silly scene yep yep
yep yep yep Oh no just
dodge I really feel like I should eat
those well not the yellow one you're
maxed out use it for Ashley if you have
ah
oh [__]
you yeah I would just go
okay
immunity he's got you Mikey hey I could
use some
backup swiped them clean the same audio
like I don't mind it's just the fs with
that if he knew how to Pilot a
helicopter what am I doing here am I
jumping off or there's a ladder to your
right why did you come up here or no
there's not a ladder to your right why
did you I don't know you didn't need
to I got shoot these
guys nice oh that's
unfortunate
yes so back down I go or yeah yeah
yeah
just I'm working on
it just
go go where toward the there's like a
gate I don't know get out of
here
I guess I should never even come here I
guess I'm
confused I'm out of
ammo this
here what am I doing I think so I don't
know check I think you're right way
Mikey where should I
go no I don't know if this right
way check your map all
right maybe you we going the right
way you're the worst
guide
yeah
yeah I
oh is that a bad guy or like
what all right so I came this way you
told me go downstairs first right check
your map again so I could go upstairs
now right yeah just do
this go up that
ladder should be in the right direction
now and
[Music]
then at least you got that
I don't know if there's anywhere to go
huh never mind I was wrong or yeah go
down there and then jump down I think
you're going back where you came but you
got to go there stay low I
think that way
yeah oh wait uh I could be wrong
certainly could be go through the go
through this tunnel behind
you that's where he and then go left can
you go left no no go up to the mid no go
go go go go go back that way go back
that way that's right think there's like
a midpoint you went all the way up you
just want to go Midway
up hope Mike's okay he's fine he can
handle
himself now go around the corner go this
way through the building and then yeah
there we
go man I got real loss there you go
thank you just go up
there I really doubted you as a guide
for second keep moving keep moving all
right now [__] you Barrel what would you
recommend I do in this situation uh yeah
rifle's
good
nice nice alien no you're
good get some
satos oh
no oh no Okay so mhm I probably
shouldn't have gone back for the
potatoes it was ammo
but no wonder how far I go back I know
where to go oh it's convenient oh
sweet yeah keep moving fast chill here
and take them out
maybe
right great
great oh [__] you Mary idiot
Mary yeah oh
[__] took a while to explode for some
reason sure
did but when he does this thing I'm
going to
run I think you already did it yeah I
would just
go uh wait a [__] you still have a
flashbang out throw that as soon as you
land why just so to stun him I don't
know he's right next to you I think but
I stunned him with my feet yeah I get
that but all
right hand gun maybe I don't
know all right yeah you were
right hand gun him in the face or
something you know shotguns good
right flashbang or hand on him in the
face now yeah he a powerful
gun nice oh thank God he stopped to
think about what he was doing wait a
minute where am I who am I
is this really who I want to
be all right wait what was the point of
this just jump down now there's a gate
right
there no it's a battle well it shouldn't
be though you could just kill
him there you go
press that switch before you DP yeah
okay
yeah this is a long thing I'll take
cover all
right
wait
what is happening why am I in World War
II
oh
[__] oh
[__] oh this is
B all
right
oh you shot that in midair I sure did do
you have health
no yeah be
careful don't worry about shooting them
um Mikey's got them just like stay in
cover and move
quickly I got shot I wasn't in cover or
quickly
shot this section's weird it's like so
un like anything else in the game
yeah like I'm
not I think I'm just
confused it's just like all of a sudden
there's there's like all this stuff
going
[Music]
on there's going to be Shield guys I put
your shotgun out reloading have already
I you know what I do not have a lot of
shotgun oh that you lost that crossbow
dude's ammo and you're empty yeah you
don't have any so never
mind I got
it Mikey or chain gun guys shooting
their own
guys oh oh [__]
nice go go go go go go go go go go don't
don't jump down came from there go right
go
back go just you can probably
have shot him
nice sorry I was conf oh wait
all right go go
right Sprint Sprint Sprint Sprint Sprint
you try oh [__] yeah go
right uh just keep running straight yeah
Mike you should take care of it I hope
yeah switch
it grenade that dude down there oh I'm
getting [__] shot yeah go left go
left nice okay you're in good shape get
help nothing I thought you
did no you have a green one that you're
fine but be careful but you're fine
where am I going um there you go I think
at this point you just got to take out
that last or you got to go to the other
oh my God okay yeah go this
way
um
nice nice [__] shoot that turret dude
if you can
yeah Mikey I thought you were on it I
don't know where he is is it that
guy no I'm going shoot him
anyway he's down by the G where am I
going like is this seems like a bad
idea yeah hope you're going to go back
down to the ground I'm pretty positive
see if you can take out that tur guy
before you do that
though oh no oh where is he yeah he's
down there he's just
you're [__] it just okay go back to the
other side no actually
[__] might be a guy coming you [__] face
there you go the last guy no damn it oh
the he reloaded during the cut scene
that's
[__] the what the cut you're fine just
okay
um
what am I doing do I jump down yeah and
then take cover can no no you're fine
you don't need you got a [__] little of
walls in between you here and then what
you're going to kill the guy and press
other switch just go there's a ladder to
your left where's the guy is right in
front of the
gate just like lob a grenade over the
top of that but okay holy [__] yeah get
that and heal he's right in front of the
gate but you're like running right in
front of
him
surprised Mike hasn't gotten him I don't
see him he's right to
left when you reload just run out and
throw a
grenade see him I see
him all right I got it I got it we equip
a grenade first you could rifle him in
the face I guess I going to Rifle him go
go go go go go go nope nope nope nope
nope did I not go out enough I think you
might have to progress further from m
keep kill him still there
but oh we got him sweet all right now he
just got to climb up this ladder oh no
he didn't I'm super confused I don't
know somebody's shooting something
unless that's my
friend a you
[__] nice a he fell right Amo get his
goodies oh no he's still on the turret I
think just open that regardless
what who's that I don't know Mikey got
him though hey I got
him just go through the gate I think the
guy's off the turret now I'm super
confused this part this part's not that
great yeah let go [__]
it who's shooting Mike it's Mike from
the
helicop yeah we got through it sweet
it's shorter to the episode copter wait
we're going to record now we can just
end
here it is shorter SEC Chopper choer
yeah see what's up these stairs if it's
a cut scene I
swear oh no oh God it's this cut
scene
Mikey hey what's up
guys
wait man he really did not wait for Leon
to get out of the way
yeah also this game just
became platoon what's going
on this was like a survival horror for a
really long
time and a boy
Mikey thanks when we get out of here
drinks are on me oh my God yeah hey I
know a good
B I'm bossing now Mikey
no
Mike I've had such a short connection
put it on my
tab Mikey
no oh that guy's near Saddler so his
RPGs are more accurate I'll make sure
you're the next to go Sadler
yeah
[Music]
Mikey hey Adrian oo I'm sorry incoming
two words Sadler you bastard why is
outgoing two words it's nothing to get
all upset about don't tell me you've
never SWAT the bothers and fly in
essence it's the same thing what did you
say insects life doesn't compare to
human lives when you've acquired this
power you too will understand
guess it's another good reason to get
the parasite out of my
body I wish you
luck sweet all right right there let's
call it an episode and we'll continue
okay on the next Resident can evil I'm
still going to pick these things up all
right
well like yeah this game became what
happened oh five is even worse in the
ending just started
becoming War mhm
I I'm so remember how close to the end
you are you're
close look look through more of this oh
[__] is this the end I don't know it
might be you're a [__] God guide okay
Mikey the guide hey I'm going to close
out this video hey find more features
hey find more reviews find more 24hour
news at gam spot